hello and welcome to this video playing
making no sense and I'm going for the
bank oh let's try something else
I have to think of all over there I'm
just not so used to the pink oh yeah
this is how they play it nowadays the
Peru know which variation I think whitey
you know I think black teams now and
Queen a six of em I was taken really
making up things as they go along
something like this is it's the line but
something like it's not really knowing
things okay
we'll see what happens
okay so he wants to play he wants to
play Knight d5 but d6 might be fine I
can take before I think 94 queenie for
Queen takes b5 should work
yeah this is the nice nice thing about
an opening like the Banco if it works it
really works
yeah Black is fine I hope at least I
think he probably should Castle and then
I've just one day for pong I hope I'm
not overlooking something basic in but I
think this tactic is working ok so
what's now easiest is to just take the
bishop just for times sake
yeah probably I do dance to that and
it's probably the easiest way of playing
okay now Knight c7 is a possibility
Queen a5 the Queen will probably move
and think I'll do here looking at this
pawn as well tonight a six night before
to put more pressure on the pawn Knight
a6 also connects rupes
so that on some lucrative one I can play
the p8 which is not so easy now rupee
one rupee eight as night xt6
yeah that didn't help
Knight takes e4 it's really shocking
move hard to get back into the game
after that
yeah doing the exchange is probably a
good decision
I'm I try to just give it back
immediately yeah
some nights you what I'm going to
happily take this the remaining points
stay week okay so here
maybe just bishop here ever take d5 I'm
threatening Bishop takes f2
there's no reason not to take it I think
yeah looks like I'm cheering up for
nothing much yeah so what's the deal I
think I want to get in d5 that would be
quite helpful and get the night away so
that a five is falling
yeah I cannot take them I cannot take
the night I have this to cover the Queen
93 I'm going to okay him I'm just going
to get rid of this it's probably the
easiest to two points is good enough but
how to how to actually end it may I can
try to get here
Bishop g7 who not sure about this maybe
push the pause okay let's push the pawn
just trying to be be quick here to
activate quickly that the see point is
just coming up the board before he gets
anything substantial on the kingside
canceled I'm not getting meted you five
time warning
hmm check my coupons just not a
stalemate place yes
okay I'm Knight takes e4 that was a bit
of a shocker I wasn't actually while he
was when he was finally deciding on the
move
I actually had some doubts if that is
working yeah this is how they play it
nowadays in the Benko with this coming
a5 stuff I think this is a line that is
seen quite frequently not totally sure
about details button okay a 426 and now
yeah you know I wasn't sure when when he
was I was maybe he can take it for ya
you know Chad I was thinking just first
ya know he's seven and you know he'll be
porn
I haven't who moves here yeah why does
winning here and first you think the
pieces there but my pieces cannot move I
was yeah
I had my doubts just when he was finally
deciding on his move I was seeing that
this can be quite a problem
it's just winning according to the
engine White is going Bishop c3 and my
group and my night they are bad yeah so
very lucky but okay he D he didn't see
that correctly yeah I know my position
is great and the way he played it his
SATs immediately losing yeah that was
the relatively best choice and now I'm
Casey for was also good aw that's a cute
more even Knight takes out a
fifty-five very nice but what I did is
also came like it's just a ton of
material oh yeah so there was this one
spot way which is one yeah it was a mean
not a conscious one but it was a bluff
basic layer it wasn't it wasn't working
okay I was lucky and if he just takes it
probably I have no way of coming back
there okay well thanks for watching